in Europe we are living longer than ever
in fact life expectancy now exceeds 80
years in most EU Member States
thanks to steady improvements in health
innovative technologies new treatments
and prevention however beyond the
encouraging averages lie stark
differences both within and between
European countries
while Europeans live longer the extra
years are not always spent in good
health while the chances for survival
from cancer heart attacks and strokes
are higher than ever around 15 million
mostly aged over 65 still suffer from
two or more of these chronic conditions
and half a million people of working age
still die from them every year
besides the human cost this translates
into a potential economic loss across
the EU of around 115 billion euros each
year so spending on health should not
just be seen as a cost it's actually an
investment governments today have to
make difficult choices in how to spend
tight budgets in fact there is wide
variation in health expenditure across
European countries with some spending 7
times more than others but that doesn't
necessarily yield better outcomes so
it's not a matter of investing more but
about investing better how then can we
help our national governments to improve
our health systems and ensure that they
are of good quality accessible and can
adapt to future challenges the European
Commission supports EU countries in
their evidence-based policymaking and
has launched a brand-new cycle of
knowledge on health a state of health in
the EU it is done in partnership with
the OECD the European Observatory on
health systems and policies and EU
Member States
newly published health at a glance
Europe report is the first step in a
two-year cycle each EU country is
different but all are under enormous
pressure to evolve modernize and adapt
to an ever-changing environment next
year the state of health in the EU will
capture clearly these differences and
shared challenges member states will
then be able to make use of the expert
analysis and information in a process of
mutual learning the Commission will be
there to support
read use and share the evidence